Fred I'm told there's something that
happened on our program fairly recently
that has you a little peeved you'd like
to get it off your chest
yeah bill hader mm-hmm from SNL is on
this show and he did an impression of me
he did an impression of you yeah and it
made you mad this impression it's just
not fair yeah here to like defend myself
so do you mind if we quickly so that
everyone is on the same page show the
clip of Bill Hader I think they'd like
to see it doing the impression of you
Fred talked to his hands and he just
talked about Portland all the time I
love Portland I fly over there I have my
apartment
[Applause]
[Music]
say not what I do there's not what to do
I never do anything like that but just
to get him back you want to get him back
now yes so so bill when every talks he's
kind of teeth her out here anything his
hands are kind of like this
one thing that he does is he kind of
rediscovers bands that we all know
already yeah you know so like he'll just
go like you know I've been listening
date yes you know yes there's like
fragile I was a pretty cool album I
really like it it was over here I think
it was he does yeah he's a little bit of
a master the iron is on The Simpsons
yeah yeah for his hands just hang right
here yeah and then he likes to end
things with the laughs of a like a
little it's like a little you know
accent at the end of it
uh-huh yes so that's my bill okay so you
feel like you got
[Applause]
you